moi et mon fils mais trahie et aux gens
d'avoir deux ans encore quitté la cité
rose c'est comme un village tout le
monde se connaît depuis deux mois soit
parce que je suis asiatique forcément
chinois mais poteau pour moi même mais
c'était jouissif jeu mais vous nous en
direz
prison le piment entier s'échangent elle
prend pas trop l'art avec c'est un puce
le toit madiba la plus chaude je connais
ça que de la gueule et ça va
dix mois tape avisma pas ça non j'aurais
dû lui dire tu séisme et il part en
couille pascal marchi rapide à mon
maximum et sarlat et à partir de
maintenant des guetteurs mon petit
requin taureau plutôt cousin le plus
haut gradé vichy c'est quoi pourtant et
imagine nous enlève notre moyen de
survie ne reste coi baignent dans l'eau
tout est pas un show c'est un jour
départ chaud
mais le monde